Google MD is what people have these days
instead of health insurance just Google
your symptoms they'll show you a
delicate watercolor image of your bone
spurs or your fecal nematodes or the
thing in your brain that's eating your
brain comedians I'm going to show you an
illustration from Google MD and for 250
points tell me what the condition
affliction or ailment is that they might
have first up let's start with this poor
guy
what's he got Jonathan bad case of
misogyny yes fine okay okay he has a
serious case of heads down thumbs up
let's play 7-up syndrome all right for
rainy days next up next up this poor guy
what's his game I saw a my of Sauron all
right boy Jonathan Stage four dumb
necklift cancer all right get it I'm
sorry I don't see anything wrong with
those beautiful brown eyes